y así es desde el banco central del
ecuador les invitamos a romper esquemas
a cambiar esa forma de pensar a veces
que tenemos de estructurada de ciertos
ámbitos sobre todo del tema económico
tal vez ahora vamos a tener esta visión
totalmente distinta del mundo para
ustedes desde el banco central del
ecuador arrancamos ya con la primera
charla en esta mañana y con un tema
bastante sugerente hablamos de cómo
partir un pastel no esperemos todavía el
tema del break no nos relacionamos
todavía con la comida sino con un tema
económico que muchos de ustedes
seguramente ya están pues acostumbrados
a escuchar la repartición de riquezas en
el país es esto posible es fácil de
lograrlo pues vamos a conocer un poco
más de este tema junto a alejandro
yerovi él es un apasionado por la
ciencia y un entusiasta de las
computadoras y un férreo creyente de la
familia estas opciones han llevado a
temas muy diversos de diversos en
algunos ámbitos desde la banca hasta la
educación pero siempre con el rigor y la
disciplina propios de las metodologías
que manejan los economistas así que
alejandro te invitamos a romper esquemas
[Aplausos]
no contaban con discusión
[Música]
hola
voy a hablarles esta mañana un poco de
mí
mi gran curiosidad y la hagan las ganas
de aprender me han llevado por diversos
caminos como ya decía bruno pase desde
estudiar economía física y matemática y
esa gran curiosidad también me ha
llevado a pensar cómo hacer más
prácticas las cosas y los temas que
aprendido por eso el día de hoy voy a
hablarles sobre cómo partir un pastel
ustedes se preguntarán este tema un poco
extraño no voy a hablarles de ningún
tema culinario ni nada gastronómico
pero imagínese en ustedes que yo le
ponía de título a la conferencia
comercio justo y economía popular y
solidaria seguramente mi mamá venía de
bent
pero al cambio vamos a hablar de
repartición y para eso tenemos tres o
tres criterios básicos para hablemos del
tema matemático del tema económico y del
tema jurídico pensando matemáticamente
suena súper fácil hacer reparticiones es
simplemente cuestión de dividir y listo
es casi como comerse una patata frita y
si lo pensamos con un ejemplo claro es
así si cogemos 100 dólares lo dividimos
para cuatro personas tenemos cuatro
partes iguales de 25 dólares genial
ahora pensemos un poco más deuda
qué tal si hacemos la división de 1 para
pensemos en la operación hacemos uno
dividido para tres y con la aproximación
que yo quiera me va a ir saliendo 0 30
33 33 33 y así el número de decimales
que yo quiera que podría ser hasta el
infinito pero eso ya sugiere una
cuestión que dificulta la repartición
porque según yo tenga los decimales va a
ir cambiando el sobrante y eso cambia la
repartición entonces ya no parece tan
fácil no es cierto bueno
pensemos ahora que ese s 1 es un dólar y
queremos repartir entre 3 personas que
tal si hay alguien tacaño vamos a
repartir este dólar y le vamos a dar 33
centavos a cada persona y por ahí qué
pasa con ese centavo bueno en fin
hablemos de otras cosas en el diario
vivir hay cosas más difíciles de
repartir que el dinero por ejemplo
hablemos de repartir una ensalada con mi
familia una ensalada de tomate lechuga y
aguacate como mi esposa y mi hijo no les
gusta para nada el aguacate la cosa se
vuelve un poco más fácil porque a mí me
encanta el aguacate yo me quedo con el
aguacate y ellos se reparten de buena
forma el tomate y la lechuga genial eso
nos trae una idea súper interesante una
idea que explotó mi mente casi como
cuando mi hija perdió a decir guau la
repartición depende de la expectativa si
depende de la expectativa y eso es algo
genial
hablando desde el punto de vista
económico
la repartición es se basa en la
optimización es decir en maximizar la
satisfacción que queremos tener y bueno
como criterio ponderador indispensable
tenemos la regla de oro el que más da
más recibe entonces tomando en cuenta el
criterio económico de si es más
importante el capital o el trabajo vamos
a tener también una distinta repartición
si es más importante el capital quien
más capital de va a recibir más dinero
pero si hablamos que es más importante
el trabajo que el capital estamos
hablando ya de el tema de los artesanos
de los emprendimientos y de la economía
popular y solidaria
el criterio jurídico es definitivamente
mandatorio la ley establece criterios de
repartición que son ya establecidos y no
podemos salirnos de ese marco así que
todo y está dado
marian recogió todo esto en dos teoremas
y formalizó el tema de la repartición
justa y el bienestar
basado en dos ideas importantes la
repartición debe ser justa y libre de
envidia que sea justa significa que el
pedazo que recibió cada persona le
satisface completamente y aun si le
cambiaran el pedazo seguiría satisfecho
que sea libre de envidia significa que
no le importan los participantes del
pedazo de las otras personas se sienten
tranquilos con sus pedazos sin estar
mirando el que tiene su compañero
los algoritmos libres de envidia
recogieron todas estas ideas
y si hablamos de la repartición de un
pastel plantean el siguiente algoritmo
digamos que queremos repartir el pastel
a lo cual yo cojo el pastel yo lo parto
pero tú escoges del pedazo eso significa
que yo estoy aquí tengo la
responsabilidad de repartirlo lo más
justamente posible porque el único que
se perjudicaría si no lo hiciera fuera
yo mismo así que yo parto de manera
correcta y ustedes escogí el pastel el
pedazo
ahora qué pasa eso para dos personas
está básico y genial pero para tres
personas resulta ser que los algoritmos
dnp pertenecen a una familia de
algoritmos los algoritmos libres de
envidia pertenecen a un grupo de
algoritmos que se son n p eso significa
que conforme crece el número de
participantes también crece la
dificultad que se tiene al repartir
recuerdan que hablábamos sobre la
expectativa vana si hacemos la
repartición digamos del pastel con mis
hijos yo voy a hacer tres pedazos y como
estos son bastante relajados y no tienen
problemas con los pasteles el pedazo que
yo les deje a ellos les va a satisfacer
y van a estar contentos con su parte
pero ahora pongamos en escenario
personas un poco más exigentes digamos
mi cuñada mi mamá y mi suegra estoy aquí
vuelve las cosas un poco más difíciles
no es cierto porque mi suegra me encanta
a partir del pastel
va a sacar un tercio y le va a pasar a
mi mamá que le va a haber cosas page y
va a decir en ese pedazo no está tan un
tercio así que tiene dos opciones le
puede si está muy grande si está más
grande de un tercio le puede partir y si
está más pequeño le debe
intacto una vez que haga esto le pase el
pedazo a mi cuñada que también va a
mirar recelos el pedazo digamos que le
gustó el pedazo que ya ya saco mi mamá y
se lo coge entonces como continuar la
solución juntamos todo lo que sobró del
pastel y hacemos el criterio de yo parto
y tú escoges entre mi suegra y mi mamá
genial pero qué pasa si dice yo ese
pedazo no me gusto mejor no lo cojo ese
pedazo entonces lo que continúa es que
como mi mamá ya partió el pedazo y para
ella y era justo era un tercio ella se
queda con ese pedazo y juntamos el nuevo
todo del pastel y hacemos el criterio de
yo parto y tú escoges entre mi suegra y
mi cuñada
ahora tenemos una siguiente opción qué
pasa si mi mamá no partió el pastel no
le parc no le saco un pedazo en ese caso
ella no acepto que el pedazo era
suficiente y si mi cuñada decidió no
aceptar el pedazo quién debería quedarse
con el pedazo inicial sería mi suegra
puesto que ella inició partiendo el
tercio así queda se quedaría con el
pedazo y de nuevo juntamos el pastel y
entre mi mamá y mi cuñada se van a hacer
el criterio de nuevo de yo parto y tú
escoges cómo ven la cosa y así complicó
bastante más y eso para tres personas
imagínense si hablamos de repartición de
riqueza de territorio y política o diego
de comercio las cosas ya requieren un
esfuerzo técnico y jurídico sumamente
grande
ahora yo dije en el aire algo que pasa
con ese centavo que nunca se repartió al
momento de partir el dólar entre 3 si
hagamos de estrictamente de forma
matemática yo debería [ __ ] al pedazo y
física al centavo y físicamente partirla
en tres lo que le haría perder su valor
y me tocaría darle un pedazo a cada
persona pero eso no está muy práctico no
es cierto pensemos en una solución más
práctica
la solución práctica sería acumular y
luego repartir por ejemplo si son
ganancias esperaríamos a que ganemos
tres dólares y en este momento tenemos
tres centavos disponibles a lo cual
vamos a repartir un centavo a cada
persona podríamos liberarlos del
sobrante podíamos regalar le podríamos
donar lo simplemente votar y ser
indiferentes antes de ese centavo otra
opción sería la reinversión si estamos
hablando de un negocio al dólar que
ganamos de 60 bolas destinamos para
mejorar nuestro negocio eso nos trae una
idea genial porque porque la cooperación
maximiza siempre los beneficios y
también nos muestra que la economía
popular y solidaria es una excelente
alternativa a los temas de repartición
por último quiero citar a nadie hablando
del equilibrio siempre el equilibrio
cooperativo es siempre mucho más
efectivo que el equilibrio individual y
para cerrar quiero dejarles con una idea
también de nada yo no creo en el azar
pero sí en darle un valor a las cosas
les agradezco muchísimo pues atención
[Aplausos]